alright so I'm gonna give you a minute
and I'm just going to talk through
what's going on and I'm gonna buy you
some time as you draw these diagrams but
the ones that don't work and maybe just
like put a little subheading to say
these don't work and that's why we're
interested in them okay
now the first thing I'm going to note is
let's have a look at the ones that do
work as you're drawing for instance who
who did the red on the blue one on this
side yeah you did the red one Kim and
okay so I want us to look at these two
now they look like different networks to
me but in many regards they're basically
the same network do you see why have a
think about this right we've all named
them ABCDE et cetera right so they both
have five vertices how many edges do
they have they both have five right and
importantly like if I just took this C
right and just like stretched it out a
little bit so it was on the outside
you're basically just getting a nice
neat you know sort of regular old not
regular but a normal Pentagon right and
so even though their appearance is
different as networks these guys are
identical which is why unsurprisingly
they both do work okay you're just gonna
start anywhere and just get all the way
around
okay now this some this is the points
right everyone this guy it oh it doesn't
work okay so this guy should be over
here now that's interesting we'll work
out why it is in a second the last one
we've got down here is um this
monstrosity that this seems pretty right
now it looks insanely complicated I mean
it has more vertices than a hostel okay
but in case you didn't hear because I
was just explaining over there even
though it looks awful
there's a very logical way in which this
is get this identical to these two watch
right let's just start from a is a nice
place to start okay if I start from a
and I'm just gonna go in alphabetical
order and I'm gonna go from A to B B to
C etc and I'm just going to go on the
inside so like this part here see that
path that sorry that edge I should say
inside edge inside inside I'm ruining my
gray mark let's find inside inside
inside inside okay so I have covered one
out of every three of the edges right
but importantly I'm back to where I
started so now I can go back to a and
stead of doing all the inside ones I
could do all the outside ones if I want
it and then I could do all the middle
ones so it's fine I can get all the way
through that okay but then we come to
these and we run into some troubles
right so for example okay Ryan you did
this one didn't you okay so why do you
think this causes a problem well how
would you describe why it's why don't
work what do you mean by going threes
I'm interested by that phrase you just
used okay that's interesting so tell me
if I'm getting if I'm gonna say to you
right right all right we just have a
look at a B and E right that's like a
miniature little circuit that you have
to go around but to do a B and E you're
like oh I'm using this AE edge that I'm
gonna need for this one down here right
for the lower bottom of the fan corner
and you're like you keep on doing this
all the way around you're like arm stock
okay this one here is interesting this
is um this is your right now yours you
created one that works and then what did
you add on to make it not work okay you
added this joint here so if you can
picture this without the d2e edge you
can see why it works right you could
just start from here and just go all the
way around we had this conversation but
can you help me with so everyone else
knows why does the d2e edge cause a
problem yep so if we started for me
right and then sort of you'd have to
make a choice at D to go left or right
and once you've gone left or right you
can never come back right and of course
as we discussed even if you don't start
at E if you start over here a right once
you get to a you go in but then you
can't you can't come back out again
right because you've used the only edge
that was available and that's actually
really important I'm gonna come back to
the point in a second last thing I want
to point out is Ryan's one and this is
yours right here yep do you see it
just like these first two you the red
and blue do you see that this orange and
red they're the same Network yeah it's
kind of like squashed in a little bit
and like
tango but it's it's got all the same
vertices it's got all the same edges it
just is a different shape slightly okay
that makes sense
all right now hopefully that's bought
enough time for you to draw these right
and now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
ask you I'm gonna introduce sorry
another word but I promise it's a useful
word and it's a really easy thing to
spot on here that I'm gonna ask you to
do the word is I'm gonna even write it
down the word is degree now I know that
we've used the word degree in the
context of angles how many degrees is
this right but in networks degree mean
something really different degree means
what will you are you like it good all
right okay so in that case what I'd like
you do is can you tell me if degree is
can you what's your definition what's
like your one sentence explanation here
isn't the amount of edges that come from
or go to a vertex right I know there's a
lot of them on here but can't husk sorry
I can almost keep you all one because
exactly the same right for these three
here I want you to draw for every vertex
that you can see can you label its
degree so for example I start us off
this one up here ions there's a three
here there's a three here there's what
is the a what's the degree V that's four
but then the rest of them are all three
okay can you do the other two that are
here which are quite different but do
all of the degrees there and then why
don't you to do is compare that to the
degrees of the other ones you've got
that work okay I'm gonna give you a
minute to do that because it takes some
time to go through okay how'd you go did
you did you label all the degrees of
everything so what you've hopefully
noticed is and I even filled in some of
the ones over here even Azam's one
because of all than that hard actually
even it looks terrible right I wonder if
you can tell what's the difference what
stands out is there anything unusual
that's shared in common between all
these guys which you notice is quite
different to over here anyone want to
make a suggestion what's the thing that
you see from on this side it's not on
that side you're going
very good so all of these ones different
amounts different degrees for every
vertex okay is this anything else that
you notice yeah go ahead right there are
our values in the degrees now this is
actually really important when you've
got like a theory you're like I haven't
a hypothesis for why this works right
she always test it out on the does not
work side of where you've drawn things
I'd like you to draw one more network
with me one that's simpler I think yeah
sleep live in all of these ones but it's
sort of going to invalidate one of our
theories and it's important to
invalidate your interviews so you know
which one's work and which ones don't
right so just put on four vertices for
me let's go on ABCD and then here's what
I'm gonna add on I'm gonna go draw all
the edges around the outside and then
draw two across like that do they don't
have one like this whoopsie-daisy it's
very similar to Ryan's and caroms but
there's just no middle thing so there's
no like middle vertex okay now just go
ahead and try it in your mind's can you
do this can you see why it doesn't work
right for example you should go all
around the edges right then you can do
one of the diagonals but you can't do
the other one right so you're like oh
great what are the degrees of a B C and
D they're all three aren't they let me
get me from telling you right three
three three three
so here all the numbers are the same but
it's so like this but it still does not
work okay so I'm going to show you is
this I'm just going to turn this back on
for a second because I think it will
make it clearer for you and don't worry
about drawing or writing this down but
later on if you want you can grab a
picture of it let's see if it wakes up
did it turn off
I reckon turned off no it is on wake up
there we go
success okay so here are some I prepared
earlier right now have a look fun little
fact by the way I asked you to do like
four or five vertices because if you do
one virtus vertex is a bit boring right
but if you did two or three it turns out
to be very difficult to make a network
that doesn't work they all seem to work
okay I'll let you train explore that
later but then have a look at these guys
do you see them right that one right
there is the one that I drew here okay
so what's going on what makes these
graphs
a problem its vertices that have an odd
degree when you have vertices which have
an odd degree like this guy here right
or this one as soon as you've got more
than two you cactus right you can have
two two is fine have a look at this guy
right do you see this one
can you go all the way around like one
two three four five all the edges are
covered yeah so two odd vertices are
okay but as soon as you've got more
you're in trouble okay now interesting
can you actually just draw this one here
for me draw this one it's just like this
one we did here and it does work but
it's got one edge less and hopefully
this will bring all of the all the
threads together for us so just draw
your four vertices first
know someone wait
okay now in this diagram and I wonder if
you can get your vertices labels to
match mine as well right a B C and D sip
are different to each other right what's
the degree of a3 what's the degree of b2
and then it goes again around the around
the diagram right now what's interesting
here is I want you to start off from
we've just established that this works
right you can totally solve this one
right but I want you now just put your
pencil or pen put it on B and then try
to try to complete go all the way
through all the bridges just give it a
go try it right now okay start on B and
see if you can go all the way around
what are you on what are you finding if
you start from B it just explodes in
your face right you're like but I
already know it works how come it can't
work if I start from B and the answer
has to do with these degrees right the
reason why it's okay to have it's okay
to have two right so long as you start
from the a or the C so long as you start
and you end on something with an odd
degree you'll be alright start on a and
it goes you're fine right
but you've started one of these guys
then you run out of edges rapidly you
sort of paint yourself into a corner
okay so can we maybe summarize this in
if we if you haven't already written
this this is probably the way that I
would sort of encapsulate like what's
the piece of theory that we've learnt
right if you have a network and it has
any more than two of these odd vertices
then you already know immediately you
can't cross every bridge without
repeating one right so you're gonna have
to backtrack or alternatively you're
gonna have to add extra things like if
you're the garbage collector or the
postal service right you're gonna have
to add some extra edges or vertices so
you can cover everything and not double
back and waste its time